This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 2005, an audience filed into the Brava Theatre Center in San Francisco. The house lights were on, making it easy to see a small group of men already on stage, wearing orange jumpsuits and lying on small prison cots. They were actors in the politically charged play, Guantanamo, honor bound to defend freedom. The show told the stories of four British Muslim detainees. The narrative unfolds through the testimony of their families, attorneys, and U.S. officials, along with letters that the men wrote while being held at Guantanamo Bay in Cuba.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2005年，观众们走进旧金山的布拉瓦剧院中心。剧院的顶灯亮着，让人能清楚地看到台上一小群身穿橙色连体衣、躺在简陋监狱行军床上的男人。他们是一部政治色彩浓厚的戏剧《关塔那摩》的演员，肩负着捍卫自由的使命。该剧讲述了四名英国穆斯林被拘留者的故事。故事通过他们的家人、律师和美国官员的证词，以及这些男子被关押在古巴关塔那摩湾期间写下的信件徐徐展开。
One of them was a guy named Ruhal Ahmed, who was from an area outside of Birmingham. And him and three of his buddies were picked up in Afghanistan and were held in Guantanamo Bay for many, many years. This is Nafis Hamid. He played the role of Ruhal in one production of the play. What I remember from being in the show was just the way in which his letters were quite spirited in the beginning. He would be talking about how all the Guantanamo Bay guards like him, how they get along. They call him Slim Shady, how he's working on a six-pack. And then by the end, his letters, you could just see, were getting more and more depressed. And you could just tell that this was someone who was entering into a dark and
其中一人名叫鲁哈尔·艾哈迈德，来自伯明翰郊区的一个地方。他和他的三个死党在阿富汗被捕，并在关塔那摩湾被关押了很多很多年。这是纳菲斯·哈米德。他在该剧的一个版本中饰演鲁哈尔的角色。我对参演这部剧的记忆是，他的信件在最开始时显得相当有朝气。他会谈到关塔那摩湾的警卫们如何喜欢他，他们如何相处融洽。他们叫他“阿姆”（Slim Shady），说他正在练六块腹肌。但到了后来，你会发现他的信件越来越沮丧。你可以看出，这是一个正在陷入黑暗且……
very, very negative state. Ruhal Ahmed was accused of being an al-Qaeda recruit, an enemy of the United States. Throughout his more than two year stint in Guantanamo, he maintained that he was innocent. He was eventually released without charges. As an actor, Nafis felt his job was to inhabit the prisoner's life and character. With any character that you play, whether they're innocent or guilty,
非常非常消极状态的人。鲁哈尔·艾哈迈德被指控为基地组织新兵、美国的敌人。在他被关押在关塔那摩两年多的时间里，他一直坚称自己是无辜的。他最终在没有受到指控的情况下被释放。作为一名演员，纳菲斯觉得他的工作就是融入囚犯的生活和性格。对于你扮演的任何角色，无论他们是无辜的还是有罪的，
you try not to judge them and try to just become one of them as much as possible. It was not the last time Nafis would try to get into the mind of a suspected terrorist. This week on Hidden Brain, we dive into the motivations of people on the brink of extremism and those who have been radicalized. We examine what prompts people to turn to violence and explore how psychological science might pull people back from the seductive appeal of extremist ideas. After a few more years in the performing arts, Nafis Hameed left acting to pursue a career in psychology. I always just had an interest in human psychology and what motivates us. I think that's part of the
你都要尽量不去评判他们，并尽可能地成为他们中的一员。这并不是纳菲斯最后一次试图走入疑似恐怖分子的内心世界。本周的“隐藏的大脑”节目中，我们将深入探讨处于极端主义边缘以及已经被激进化的人们的动机。我们审视是什么促使人们转向暴力，并探讨心理学科学如何能够将人们从极端主义思想的诱惑中拉回来。在表演艺术领域又度过了几年之后，纳菲斯·哈米德离开了演艺界，转而追求心理学的事业。我一直对人类心理学以及我们的动机感兴趣。我想这也是我
reason why I also was interested in acting. To me that's just another way of trying to understand a more embodied, more intuitive way of trying to understand human psychology. Nafis went on to study cognitive science, but he still craved drama and excitement and wanted to get into a field of research that would take him all over the world. So he sought out cultural anthropologist and former guest of the show, Scott Attrin. At the time, Scott was studying terrorist groups. You know, I really wanted to work with Scott and he was, I think he probably had some interest in working with me, but he, you know, pawned me off to another academic who was there at Oxford, because that person was maybe more in a position to take on a PhD student. That person tried to pawn me off to another academic at the University of Belfast. Past the hot potato here. Exactly.
对表演感兴趣的部分原因。对我来说，这只是试图理解人类心理学的另一种更具沉浸感、更直观的方式。纳菲斯接着学习了认知科学，但他仍然渴望戏剧性和刺激，并希望进入一个能带他走遍世界的科研领域。于是，他找到了文化人类学家、本节目的前嘉宾斯科特·阿特兰。当时，斯科特正在研究恐怖组织。你知道，我真的很想和斯科特一起工作，我想他可能也有兴趣和我合作，但是，你知道的，他把我“击鼓传花”般推给了牛津大学的另一位学者，因为那个人可能更有资格接收博士生。那个人又试图把我推给贝尔法斯特大学的另一位学者。在这里玩烫手山芋的游戏。没错。
Exactly. Living in Belfast and doing research on historical conflict in Northern Ireland was not what Nafis had imagined for himself. This was in 2013, the Arab Spring. Pro-democracy protests were spreading across the Middle East and Northern Africa. Jihadist groups, clusters of violent Islamic militias, were forming at a fast pace. In Syria, young men from around the world were gathering. They wanted to overthrow Syria's authoritarian leader,
没错。住在贝尔法斯特并研究北爱尔兰的历史冲突，并不是纳菲斯为自己想象的生活。那是2013年，正值“阿拉伯之春”。民主抗议活动正在中东和北非蔓延。圣战组织——大大小小的暴力伊斯兰民兵组织——正在快速形成。在叙利亚，来自世界各地的年轻人聚集在一起。他们想要推翻叙利亚的独裁领导人
Bashar al-Assad. They didn't always know what they were fighting for. They weren't necessarily going always to become a Jihadist themselves. But it was a sort of a sense of like, this is for a lot of young Muslim youth, this was their equivalent of being able to say, this is my hero's journey is about to begin.
巴沙尔·萨阿德。他们并不总是知道自己在为之战斗的是什么。他们不一定总是自己去成为一个圣战者。但这是一种感觉，对于许多年轻的穆斯林青年来说，这相当于他们能够说：“我的英雄之旅即将开始。”
I'm going to go and maybe I'll die, but I'm going to go fight for the plight of the Muslim people in Syria and save them from this brutal dictator. Outside of adventure and curiosity, Nafis had another motivator for studying radicalized Islamic groups. His own upbringing
我要去那里，也许我会死，但我去是为了叙利亚穆斯林同胞的苦难而战，把他们从这个残酷的独裁者手中拯救出来。除了冒险和好奇心，纳菲斯研究激进伊斯兰群体的另一个动力是，他自己的成长经历
mirrored that of many of the people Scott was studying. Nafis was raised Muslim by his Pakistani father and Indian mother, and he spoke many of the same languages as the jihadist recruits. In a way, he felt like he was the perfect candidate for this kind of work. One day, he made his views known over dinner with Scott and other academics, perhaps a tad forcefully. I was a little drunk, so I said something I probably wouldn't have said, which is just, are you kidding me? This is 2013. And I'm like, we have right now, you know, this huge foreign fighter exodus going on of people who are pretty
与斯科特正在研究的许多人的经历如出一辙。纳菲斯由他的巴基斯坦父亲和印度母亲抚养长大，信仰伊斯兰教，他会说许多与圣战分子新兵相同的语言。在某种程度上，他觉得自己是做这种工作的完美人选。一天，他和斯科特及其他学者共进晚餐时，发表了自己的看法，语气可能稍微有点强势。我当时有点喝多了，所以说了一些我平时可能不会说的话，那就是：开什么玩笑？现在是2013年。我说，我们现在有，你知道的，大量的外籍战斗人员外流，这些人
close to my profile, who are pretty close to my age. They look like me, they speak some of the same languages that I speak, same kind of background. And they're all going from all thousands of them from all over the world are going to Syria to go join groups like ISIS and al-Qaeda. And you want me to go to Northern Ireland to hang out with former IRA people? Who's gonna go talk to these people? Who's gonna be able to relate to them? Who's gonna be able to put himself in their shoes, like an actor portraying these people eventually, absorb their thinking, be able to come back and communicate it not only to you, but to policy makers and to the media so that way people can understand
和我的情况非常接近，年龄也和我差不多。他们看起来像我，说一些和我一样的语言，背景也大致相同。成千上万的人从世界各地涌向叙利亚，去加入ISIS和基地组织这样的组织。而你却想让我去北爱尔兰和前爱尔兰共和军的人混在一起？谁去和这些人谈谈？谁能与他们产生共鸣？谁能设身处地为他们着想，就像一个演员最终去刻画这些人、吸收他们的思想，并能够回来不仅向你们传达，还要向政策制定者和媒体传达，这样人们才能理解
and relate to it in order to eventually combat it. I said to those researchers, you're asking me to operate with one hand tied behind my back. I have more to offer than just being a scientist. I have friends who are better scientists than me. If That's what you just want as an academic. I'll introduce you to other academics. You don't need me. And I could tell again Scott sort of like the chutzpah that I showed in that moment and that's when he and another person he was working with offered me a job. The job was more of what Nafis had in mind. It involved moving to Spain to find, interview,
并与之产生共鸣，最终战胜他们。我对那些研究人员说，你们要求我绑起一只手来工作。我能提供的不仅仅是一名科学家。我有比我更好的科学家朋友。如果这就是你们作为学者所想要的。我可以把你们介绍给其他学者。你们不需要我。我能看出斯科特对我在那一刻表现出的傲慢有点欣赏，就在那时，他和他的另一个合作伙伴给了我一份工作。这份工作更符合纳菲斯的设想。它包括搬到西班牙去寻找、采访
and perform brain scans on men nearly or fully entrenched in extremist Islamic groups. The research project was designed to evaluate the lengths these men would go to defend what psychologists call sacred values. would go to defend what psychologists call sacred values? Yeah, so sacred values are values that are of the utmost importance to us. They are values that you cannot engage with them or trade them off for the material aspects of the world. I can't buy this value off you. You're going to reject any kind of economic incentive that I make. There's almost an element of purity to it. Nafis wanted to understand what was happening in the minds of people who held sacred values.
并对深度或完全陷入极端伊斯兰组织的人进行脑部扫描。这个研究项目旨在评估这些人为了捍卫心理学家所说的“神圣价值观”愿意付出多大代价。为了捍卫心理学家所说的神圣价值观，他们愿意走多远？是的，所以神圣价值观是对我们至关重要的价值观。它们是那些你无法与之妥协，也无法用世界的物质利益去交换的价值观。我无法从你这里买断这个价值观。你会拒绝我提出的任何经济激励。它几乎带有一点纯洁的色彩。纳菲斯想要了解那些持有神圣价值观的人的心智中究竟发生了什么。
But before he could do that, he had to recruit volunteers for the study. He was working in Barcelona, a city with small, concentrated areas known to be breeding grounds for extremists. Nafis had no idea how to find would-be extremists, so he drew on his acting background. He decided to pretend to be an extremist himself. So one of my first ridiculous attempts was that I just went to cafes, opened up my laptop in like kind of Muslim dense areas, downloaded an ISIS video, started to watch that with the volume on full blast, thinking that maybe someone might walk behind me and be like, hey, is that the latest drop? Let's sit down. Are you a fan? Let's sit down and have a chat. And luckily all that happened was that the manager of that cafe, who was also Muslim, kicked me out and threatened
但在他做到这一点之前，他必须为这项研究招募志愿者。他在巴塞罗那工作，这是一个有着被称为极端主义滋生地的、小型且集中区域的城市。纳菲斯不知道如何找到潜在的极端主义者，于是他利用了自己的表演背景。他决定假装自己也是一个极端主义者。所以我的第一次荒谬尝试之一就是，我去咖啡馆，在穆斯林人口较多的地区打开笔记本电脑，下载了一部ISIS的视频，然后把音量开到最大开始观看，心想可能会有人从我身后走过，然后说：“嘿，这是最新发布的视频吗？我们坐下来聊聊。你是粉丝吗？坐下来聊聊吧。”幸运的是，发生的一切只是那家咖啡馆的经理（他也是个穆斯林）把我赶了出去，并威胁说
that I might get the cops called on me if I pull anything like this again. The YouTube videos were not a total loss. Quite a few of them were posted by a man living right outside of Barcelona. Surprisingly, when Nafis reached out and explained his research project, the man invited him to his apartment. I get to his flat and there's already a couple guys who are there in the kind of the living space and him and I are talking. He brings me into the kitchen where he's doing some stuff there and we sit down and we start talking and we're speaking to each other in French and he's telling me about his ideology and his way of thinking about the role and it's very clear to me very quickly that this guy is supporter of the sort of global jihadi movement.
如果我再搞这种把戏，就要报警抓我。YouTube视频并非完全没有收效。其中相当一部分是由一个住在巴塞罗那郊外的男人发布的。出人意料的是，当纳菲斯联系并解释了他的研究项目时，这个男人邀请他去了自己的公寓。我到了他的公寓，起居空间里已经有几个家伙在那儿了，我和他在说话。他把我带到厨房，他在那里弄点东西，我们坐下来开始交谈，我们用法语交谈，他向我讲述他的意识形态和对这种角色的思考方式，我很快就非常清楚地看出这家伙是全球圣战运动的支持者。
We're having this conversation and it's all going fine but then he starts to get more and more animated. He asked me where I'm from and I was honest. I told him I'm American. He knew I was a researcher that I'm trying to study this way of thinking. And then he starts saying some stuff like, you know, we can't trust anybody as Muslims were persecuted everywhere we go. And then he says basically, you know, why should I even trust you? You're an American. And then he says, why should I even let you out of my flat? And that's when I realize, OK, things are really turning
我们正在进行对话，一切都很顺利，但接着他开始变得越来越激动。他问我来自哪里，我很诚实。我告诉他我是美国人。他知道我是一名研究人员，我正试图研究这种思维方式。然后他开始说一些诸如“你知道的，我们不能信任任何人，作为穆斯林，我们无论走到哪里都受到迫害”之类的话。接着他基本上说：“我凭什么信任你？你是个美国人。”然后他说：“我凭什么让你走出我的公寓？”就在那时我意识到，好吧，事情在这里真的开始向
sideways here. Narfis decided to appeal to the young man's vanity, his desire to be an influencer. Listen, I saw your YouTube channel. No one's watching your videos. You know, you had like 68 views. You have like whatever, like 200 followers or something. I am a researcher. My articles will be published in, you know, major academic journals.
糟糕的方向发展了。纳菲斯决定迎合这个年轻人的虚荣心，利用他成为网红的渴望。听着，我看了你的YouTube频道。根本没有人看你的视频。你知道的，你只有大约68次观看。你大概只有……比如200个粉丝左右。我是一名研究人员。我的文章将发表在（你知道的）各大主流学术期刊上。
I have the potential to, if I can understand you, I have the potential to get your message out to a broader audience. I'm not here to be your mouthpiece, but I can at least communicate what you think and your ideas to a wider audience because you can't do it on your own and you're not doing, you're not succeeding on your own." And he kind of laughed it off. He thought that was a little funny and he was like, all right, fine. And then he then just continued on with the conversation. But I could tell there was something that's off now. It's not really the same dynamic. He leaves the kitchen, he leaves me there. And I hear him in the other room speaking to these two guys in the Dharija.
我有潜力——如果我能理解你——我有潜力把你的信息传达给更广泛的受众。我来这里不是为了当你的喉舌，但我至少可以把你的想法和观点传达给更广泛的受众，因为你自己做不到，而且你也没有独自取得成功。”他笑笑把这事带过了。他觉得这有点可笑，然后就说：“好吧，行吧。”接着他就继续谈话了。但我能看出现在的气氛有点不对劲了。动态已经不完全一样了。他离开厨房，把我留在那儿。我听到他在另一个房间里用达里加语跟那两个家伙说话。
Nafi spoke Urdu, which shares some words with Dharija. As he eavesdropped on the men in the next room, one word kept popping out. I hear him say this word again and again, monophic, monophic, monophic. And monophic is a word that kind of means, at best, traitor. At worst, it means a fake Muslim. Someone who's saying he's a Muslim,
纳菲斯会说乌尔都语，乌尔都语与达里加语有一些相同的词汇。当他偷听隔壁房间那些人的谈话时，有一个词不断地蹦出来。我听到他一遍又一遍地说这个词：monophic，monophic，monophic。而monophic这个词的意思，往好了说，有点像叛徒。往坏了说，它意味着一个假穆斯林。一个嘴上说自己是穆斯林，
but is basically not a Muslim. And I realize they're talking about me. Navies knew that for some Muslims with extremist views, being a fake Muslim was a sin punishable by death. Frightened for his life, he tried to figure out how to escape. He could not exit through the front door without alerting the three men in the next room. It was at that moment he remembered a story that Scott Attrin had told him. When he was in Indonesia, he got into a bit of trouble with some jihadis there, and how he had to jump out of a window while he was using the bathroom to get out of that situation.
但实际上根本不是穆斯林的人。我意识到他们在讨论我。纳菲斯知道，对于某些持有极端主义观点的穆斯林来说，做一个假穆斯林是罪无可恕、会被处以死刑的。由于生命受到威胁，他开始琢磨如何逃跑。他无法从前门离开，否则会惊动隔壁房间的那三个男人。就在那时，他想起了斯科特·阿特兰曾对他说过的一个故事。当年在印尼时，他曾和那里的某些圣战分子惹上过麻烦，他是如何在上厕所时从窗户跳出去才脱离那种险境的。
I'm glad I had that conversation with him, because that is what caused me at that moment to look out and see that there's a window in this room. There was only one problem. He couldn't just jump out the window like Scott had done because this apartment was on the second floor. Nafis opened the window and saw there was a narrow ledge outside. Terrified by the men in the next room, he stepped out onto the ledge.
我很庆幸自己曾与他有过那次对话，因为正是那段对话让我当时环顾四周，发现这个房间里也有一扇窗户。只有一个问题。他不能像斯科特那样直接跳窗逃生，因为这套公寓在二楼。纳菲斯打开窗户，看到外面有一个窄窄的壁架。由于害怕隔壁房间的男人们，他踏上了那个壁架。
I'm hanging on the ledge of the side of this building. There's an awning of like a store or something underneath me. I just momentarily balance my foot on the awning, but immediately the awning kind of cracks. So I fall, but I fall into the awning, which mostly broke my fall. I completely shattered the awning kind of cracks. So I fall, but I fall into the awning, which mostly broke my fall. I completely shattered the awning. Luckily, I didn't hit the ground too hard. And I was able to just get basically just as soon as as soon as I got my feet on the ground, I just ran to the train station as fast as I could. And stupidly, when I get to the train
我挂在这栋建筑侧面的壁架上。我下方是一个商店或其他什么的遮阳篷。我用脚在遮阳篷上短暂地平衡了一下，但遮阳篷瞬间就裂开了。所以我掉了下去，但我落在了遮阳篷上，这在很大程度上缓冲了我的下落。我把遮阳篷彻底砸碎了……裂开了。所以我掉了下去，但我落在了遮阳篷上，这在很大程度上缓冲了我的下落。我把遮阳篷彻底砸碎了。幸运的是，我落地时冲击力不是太大。我一双脚落地后，就以最快的速度向火车站跑去。而蠢的是，当我到达火车站时，
station, I realize that the next train is in an hour and 27 minutes. I'm like, okay, this is not the right move. But luckily, there was a taxi outside. So I got that the next train is in an hour and 27 minutes. I'm like, okay, this is not the right move. But luckily there was a taxi outside, so I got into the taxi and told them to go towards Barcelona. Wow. So this was your introduction to trying to find these people. This didn't dissuade you at this point from saying, you know, maybe I should go back to acting? I mean, it's all acting, right?
我发现下一班火车还要在一个小时二十七分钟后。我想，好吧，这可不是什么明智的举动。但幸运的是，外面停着一辆出租车。所以我搭上了……下一班火车还要在一个小时二十七分钟后。我想，好吧，这可不是什么明智的举动。但幸运的是，外面停着一辆出租车，所以我上了出租车，告诉司机开往巴塞罗那。哇。所以这就是你初次尝试寻找这些人的经历。此时此刻，这并没有打消你的念头，让你觉得：“你知道的，也许我该回去演戏？”我的意思是，这不都是演戏吗，对吧？
But I mean, it's like, I wanted adventures, right? I mean it's all acting right I mean it's but I mean it's like it's it's I mean this I wanted adventures right I wanted excitement I wanted to you know I didn't I didn't want stunt doubles I wanted to be my own stunt double so here I was you know getting what I asked for. When we come back, Nafis finds a slightly more boring but also less dangerous way to talk to extremists. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Nafis Hamid is a cognitive scientist at King's College London. As a young doctoral student, he wanted to identify what factors push people to become violent extremists. While conducting
但我的意思是，就像，我想要冒险，对吧？我的意思是，这不都是演戏吗，对吧？我的意思是，但这就像是……我的意思是，我想要冒险，对吧？我想要刺激，我想要，你知道的，我不需要替身演员，我想成为自己的特技替身。所以在这里，我得到了我所要求的。稍后回来，纳菲斯将找到一种稍微有些无聊但同样不那么危险的方式来与极端主义者对话。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。纳菲斯·哈米德是伦敦国王学院的认知科学家。作为一名年轻的博士生，他想要找出是什么因素促使人们成为暴力极端分子。在开展
research in Barcelona, his first few attempts to find volunteers to take part in his studies failed. But he did eventually discover a better way to connect with radicalized Muslim men. One of the best ways was to use a fixer. Someone from the area who was already trusted by the communities could speak their languages and understood their cultural norms. Nafis found a few young men who fit the bill and hired them as research assistants. One of them especially stood out.
研究期间，他最初几次在巴塞罗那寻找志愿者参与研究的尝试都失败了。但他最终确实发现了一种与激进化的穆斯林男性建立联系的更好方法。其中最好的方法之一就是使用一个“中间人”（fixer）。一个当地人，已经赢得了社区的信任，会说他们的语言，并且理解他们的文化规范。纳菲斯找到了几个符合要求的年轻人，并雇他们做研究助理。其中一人格外引人注目。
And at first, I wasn't sure whether he was going to be a good research assistant or not, just because he didn't have a university degree or anything. He didn't even have like a normal high school diploma. But turned out he was amazing. I mean, he spoke something like six languages fluently, very charismatic, full of personality, had big dreams and ambitions, wanted to be a professional athlete, wanted to be a musician, wanted to go into the arts. After meeting me, he wanted to be a researcher, just a really, you know, charismatic individual, and he knew everyone.
起初，我不确定他是否能成为一个好的研究助理，因为他没有大学学位什么的。他甚至连普通的高中毕业证都没有。但事实证明他太棒了。我的意思是，他能流利地说大约六种语言，非常有个人魅力，充满个性，有着宏大的梦想和抱负，想成为一名职业运动员，想成为一名音乐家，想从事艺术行业。在认识我之后，他想成为一名研究人员，真的就是一个非常（你知道的）富有个人魅力的人，而且他认识所有人。
And so he and I together in the beginning started to go out and and meet people and he would introduce me to the to the right kinds of characters and then it kind of just snowballs from there. You kind of get eventually more and more extremist people. They focused on recruiting volunteers from Moroccan and Pakistani immigrant communities. on recruiting volunteers from Moroccan and Pakistani immigrant communities. To Nafis' surprise, many young men were excited about the possibility of having their brains scanned. People found that interesting, to be honest. Even when I got to the most extreme people, the most radicalized people who were openly telling me about their support for Al-Qaeda or for other groups, when they would hear that, they became curious.
因此，起初我和他一起开始外出结识人们，他会把我引荐给合适类型的人物，然后事情就像滚雪球一样发展起来。你最终会接触到越来越多极端主义的人。他们专注于从摩洛哥和巴基斯坦移民社区招募志愿者。专注于从摩洛哥和巴基斯坦移民社区招募志愿者。令纳菲斯惊讶的是，许多年轻人对自己的大脑被扫描的可能性感到兴奋。老实说，人们觉得这很有趣。甚至当我接触到最极端的人、最激进的人（他们公开向我倾诉他们对基地组织或其他组织的支持）时，当他们听到这个，他们都产生了好奇。
They wanted to know more about, well, what does previous neuroscience say? What are your hypotheses about this? And then some of them also were a bit narcissistic, too. They were like, oh, my brain is very special. You're going to discover that. Just wait until you see my brain. One guy was like, OK, fine.
他们想了解更多关于过去的神经科学都说了什么。你对此有什么假设？然后他们中的一些人也有些自恋。他们会说：“哦，我的大脑非常特别。你会发现这一点的。等着瞧吧，看看我的大脑。”有个家伙说：“好吧，行吧，
I will participate in your study, but only under one condition. He kind of looks around like he's about to tell me something very secretive and he goes, I want a picture of my brain just to prove to my mother that I have one. Nafis and his team conducted the first set of brain scans on a group of Moroccan men whose families had been living in Barcelona for a few generations. These were men on the edge of radicalization, open about their willingness to fight or even die for their beliefs, but who hadn't yet committed themselves to a group like ISIS
我会参与你们的研究，但只有一个条件。”他环顾四周，仿佛要告诉我什么非常机密的事情，然后他说：“我想要一张我大脑的照片，好向我母亲证明我确实有一个。”纳菲斯和他的团队对一组摩洛哥男性进行了第一轮脑部扫描，这些人的家族已经在巴塞罗那生活了好几代。这些人处于激进化的边缘，毫不掩饰自己为了信仰而战甚至牺牲的意愿，但他们尚未真正投身于ISIS
or Al-Qaeda. Nafis wanted to better understand what might prompt these men to make the leap to join extremist groups. So he set up a video game called Cyberball, a virtual soccer game. When a volunteer sat down to play, he'd see four avatars on the screen. One of them represents them. It's their little avatar. And then there's three other avatars of three other players. They can see faces of those three players. They look like Spanish or Catalan players. They have names underneath them that are very typical, stereotypical Catalan male names. And they're told that these three players are three other real people who are sitting in rooms as well.
或基地组织等组织。纳菲斯希望更好地了解是什么促使这些人迈出跨越到极端组织的关键一步。于是他设置了一个名为Cyberball（网络球）的视频游戏，这是一个虚拟足球游戏。当志愿者坐下来玩游戏时，他会在屏幕上看到四个头像。其中一个是代表他们自己的。那是他们的小头像。然后还有三个头像代表其他三个玩家。他们可以看到这三个玩家的面孔。他们看起来像是西班牙或加泰罗尼亚的玩家。他们名字下方是极具加泰罗尼亚男性特征的典型名字。并且他们被告知这三个玩家也是坐在房间里的真实人物。
So they think they're real people. The task is simple. You're just going to press this little button on this computer, and you can pass the ball towards any of the other three players that you want to. They'll then pass the ball back to you. Unknown to the participants, the other three avatars were not real players. They were part of the experimental team.
所以他们以为这些人是真人。任务很简单。你只需要按下电脑上的这个小按钮，就可以把球传给你想要的另外三个玩家中的任何一个。然后他们会把球传回给你。而参与者不知道的是，另外三个头像并不是真正的玩家。他们是实验团队的一部分。
Nafis had split the volunteers into two groups. The men in the first group would play the game for a while, just passing the ball back and forth with the other avatars. But for the volunteers in the second group, things played out differently. They pass the ball to the other players, maybe the ball gets passed to them once or twice, but then the other players basically stop tossing the ball back to them.
纳菲斯将志愿者分成了两组。第一组的男性将玩一会儿游戏，只是与其他头像来回传球。但对于第二组的志愿者来说，情况则有所不同。他们把球传给其他玩家，也许球被传给他们一两次，但随后其他玩家基本上就不再把球传回给他们了。
And the three ostensibly Spanish Roquetalon players basically just start tossing the ball back and forth to each other. The Moroccan volunteer would be deliberately excluded from the game. His avatar left standing with nothing to do but watch. Once the volunteers had played the game, they were asked to get into an fMRI machine. Just a big magnetic tube that they lay down in, they slide into it, and then they look up at a screen basically, and what they're seeing is a value. These were not numerical values, but values that the volunteers had been surveyed on before. Non-sacred values such as halal food should be served in hospitals, jails, and schools,
这三个表面上看起来是西班牙或加泰罗尼亚的玩家基本上就开始互相传球了。而那个摩洛哥志愿者则被刻意排除在游戏之外。他的头像被晾在一边，无事可做，只能看着。志愿者玩完游戏后，被要求进入一台fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）机器。就是一个他们躺在里面的巨大磁性管子，他们滑进去，基本上抬头看着一个屏幕，他们看到的是一个价值观。这些不是数字价值观，而是志愿者在之前接受过调查的价值观。非神圣价值观，例如清真食品应该在医院、监狱和学校供应，
or sacred values like Western military forces should be expelled from Muslim lands. Underneath the value they then see a scale, a one to seven scale, and that's a fight and die scale. So for one it says how much are you willing to do for this value? One being, I'm not willing to do anything at all. And then seven being, I'm willing to fight and die. Previous research that Nafis and other cognitive scientists had done had revealed a trend. When someone was on the edge of radicalization, an experience of social exclusion would often push them over the trend. When someone was on the edge of radicalization, an experience of social exclusion would often push them over the edge. The results of the cyberball study mirrored this finding.
或者是神圣价值观，例如西方军事力量应该被驱逐出穆斯林土地。在价值观下方，他们会看到一个量表，一个一到七的量表，这是一个“战斗与牺牲”量表。对于数值“1”，它代表你愿意为这个价值观付出多少努力？“1”代表我根本不愿意为此做任何事。而“7”代表我愿意为之战斗并牺牲。纳菲斯和其他认知科学家之前进行的研究揭示了一个趋势。当某人处于激进化的边缘时，社交排斥的经历往往会将其推向趋势。当某人处于激进化的边缘时，社交排斥的经历往往会将他们推向边缘。Cyberball研究的结果印证了这一发现。
Volunteers who were excluded during the virtual soccer game became more willing to fight and die for their sacred values, and for non-sacred values as well. And not only that, we saw that behaviorally when we retested people for their sacred non-circuit values, more of the values that were previously labeled as non-sacred started to get categorized as sacred when they went through the psychometric tests. If a trivial act of exclusion in a video game could change how volunteers felt about serious issues, what might be the effect of more serious forms of exclusion in real life? What I think is going on here,
在虚拟足球游戏中被排挤的志愿者，变得更愿意为他们的神圣价值观（以及非神圣价值观）战斗和牺牲。不仅如此，我们在对人们的神圣和非神圣价值观进行重新测试时，在行为上也看到了这一点：更多以前被标记为非神圣的价值观，在经历心理测量测试时，开始被归类为神圣的。如果视频游戏中微不足道的排挤行为都能改变志愿者对严肃问题的感受，那么现实生活中更严重的排斥形式会产生什么影响呢？我认为这里发生的情况是，
mixing in my qualitative observations and looking at other research, is that when people feel, many of us hold multiple identities, and certainly second generation Moroccan youth in Spain are no different. They hold multiple identities, from Moroccan to Spanish, they're young,
结合我的定性观察以及对其他研究的审视，当人们感到——我们许多人都拥有多重身份，西班牙的第二代摩洛哥青年当然也不例外。他们拥有多重身份，从摩洛哥人到西班牙人，他们很年轻，
they're a Barça football team fan. They associate with different political movements as well. When you feel rejected by a particular group, especially if it's the majority group, you're probably out of the different groups that you belong to. You're going to find solace in that one group that actually presents itself as your defender, as the group that is there to get your back, to be your fellow gang members, to protect you against that group that just rejected you. That group is now going to gain an attraction a lot
他们是巴萨足球队的球迷。他们也与不同的政治运动产生认同。当你感觉到被某个特定群体拒绝时，特别是如果那是多数群体，在你所属的不同群体中，你可能会感到被排挤。你会在那个真正将自己表现为你的保护者、作为支持你、成为你的黑帮同伙、保护你免受那个刚刚拒绝你的群体伤害的群体中寻求慰藉。那个群体现在将获得大得多的吸引力。
more. I mean in some ways this speaks to sort of the deep-rooted need we all have to find acceptance. So in some ways when we don't have acceptance in one area of our lives, it's perhaps not irrational that we will seek acceptance in another area of our lives. Yeah, I think belonging is just one of those sort of very basic human needs. It's as social animals, it's where we feel safest. You know, evolutionarily, if one of us, if we're as a lone animal out there in the wilderness, we're in huge danger. Social exclusion isn't the only thing that pushes people toward extremism.
我的意思是，在某种程度上，这说明了我们所有人内心深处对寻找接纳的根深蒂固的需求。所以在某种程度上，当我们生活的某个领域没有得到接纳时，我们会在生活的另一个领域寻求接纳，这或许并非不理性。是的，我认为归属感只是那种非常基本的人类需求之一。作为社会性动物，那是我们感到最安全的地方。你知道，从进化角度来看，如果我们中的一个人，如果我们作为荒野中的一只孤立动物，我们就会处于巨大的危险之中。社会排斥并不是把人们推向极端主义的唯一因素。
Nafis and other researchers have noted that it's often a cascade of life events combined with an experience of social exclusion that leads to radicalization. He witnessed this firsthand while working with that charismatic research assistant who had helped him find volunteers for the brain imaging study. So I think he, in the beginning,
纳菲斯和其他研究人员已经注意到，通常是一连串的生活事件结合了社会排斥的经历，才会导致激进化。他在与那位曾帮他寻找脑部成像研究志愿者的极具个人魅力的研究助理共事时，亲眼目睹了这一点。所以我想他一开始，
sort of saw me as a little bit of like an older brother figure. And he wanted to share all of his passions with me and all of his big goals that he had in his life and how he really wanted to become somebody. But then over the course of our field work, he started to, I could just see kind of go into a darker and darker place. In the beginning I could just kind of see it in his mood and his energy.
多少把我当成了一个老大哥似的人物。他想和我分享他的所有激情，以及他在生活中的所有宏伟目标，还有他如何真正渴望成材。但随后在我们的实地考察过程中，我能看出他开始走向一个越来越黑暗的地方。一开始我只能从他的情绪和能量中看出这一点。
And a lot of it started off with issues that he was having with his father who basically just wanted him to go get a job to help support the family some kind of menial work and really denigrated his high-minded ambitions. Then he had a best friend whose life went into like a very negative direction and he basically lost contact with his best friend so he started to feel more alone because of that. The punches just kept coming. Next, his family found out that he had secretly been dating a Spanish woman who was in Muslim
这一切很大程度上始于他和父亲之间的问题。他的父亲基本上只想让他去找份工作来贴补家用，做点粗笨的体力活，并且极力贬低他那些高远的大志。然后他有一个挚友，生活走向了非常消极的方向，他基本上和这位挚友失去了联系，正因如此，他开始感到更加孤独。打击接踵而至。接下来，他的家人发现他一直在秘密约会一个非穆斯林的西班牙女性，
and forced them to break up. He told me that he was just walking around Barcelona all the time until 3am in the morning sometimes, chain smoking. And he would be watching videos a lot and he couldn't sleep and he had insomnia and I could tell he was kind of getting into a depressed state. And then over time he started talking about some political issues. And I could see that there was this bubbling sympathy for extremist groups. He would be talking about the Taliban. And he'd be saying how the Taliban are being bombed on Pakistani soil by the US government,
并强迫他们分手。他告诉我，他有时候在巴塞罗那到处闲逛到凌晨三点，烟不离手。他看了很多视频，无法入睡，患上了失眠症，我能看出他正陷入一种抑郁状态。随着时间的推移，他开始谈论一些政治问题。我能看出，他对极端主义组织有着萌芽般的同情。他会谈论塔利班。他会说塔利班如何在巴基斯坦本土遭到美国政府的轰炸，
and how these are our people, and this is, you know, we should be talking to them. And then he started talking about foreign fighters going to Syria and how, you know, when foreign fighters came to Spain, they were considered heroes. When they're going to Syria, they're considered traitors, probably because they're just Muslims. So this is hypocrisy. And they started showing me videos that he was watching, and some of them were ISIS propaganda videos about how ISIS was opening up schools and hospitals in Syria and so this is the stuff you never see in the mainstream media.
以及这些人是我们的同胞，这是（你知道的）我们应该和他们对话的对象。然后他开始谈论前往叙利亚的外籍战斗人员，以及（你知道的）当外籍战斗人员来到西班牙时，他们被视为英雄。当他们去叙利亚时，他们却被视为叛徒，可能只是因为他们是穆斯林。所以这是虚伪。接着他开始向我展示他一直在观看的视频，其中一些是关于ISIS在叙利亚开设学校和医院的ISIS宣传视频，所以这些是你从未在主流媒体上看到的东西。
This is what these guys are actually doing on the ground. And so I realized I have to intervene. I have to do something. Nafis asked his research assistant to meet in a tree-lined promenade in an immigrant neighborhood of the city. He waited on a bench and waited and waited. First of all, he shows up very late, which again is not like him, but he shows up very late and I can remember seeing him from a distance walking over to me, shoulders slumped, hands in his pockets, just kind of a shell of the guy that I
这就是这些家伙在实地真正做的事情。所以我意识到我必须干预。我必须做点什么。纳菲斯约他的研究助理在城市一个移民聚居区的林荫大道见面。他在长凳上等啊等，等了又等。首先，他迟到了很久，这再次不符合他的风格，但他迟到了很久，我记得从远处看到他向我走来，双肩下垂，双手插在口袋里，简直就是我记忆中那个充满人格魅力的家伙的一个空壳。
remember with so much charisma. And he knows I want to talk to him about something related to what he's been showing me. And he comes and he sits next to me on the bench, his arms are crossed, he's not even really looking at me, he's kind of looking off in the other direction. And I just start telling him, you know, these videos you're watching, these are crazy, this is propaganda, they're just taking advantage of you, you don't even understand who these people are, these are terrorist groups, they're murderers, they're killing everyone, and they're just completely brainwashing you and taking advantage of your vulnerable state.
而且他知道我想跟他谈谈关于他一直在向我展示的那些东西的话题。他走过来，坐在我旁边的长凳上，双臂交叉，甚至没有真正看着我，而是把目光投向了另一个方向。我开始对他说，你知道的，你正在看的这些视频太疯狂了，这是宣传，他们只是在利用你，你甚至不了解这些人是谁，这些是恐怖组织，他们是杀人犯，他们在杀害所有人，他们完全是在对你进行洗脑，并利用你脆弱的状态。
And what was his reaction when you said this? Did he say, thanks for setting me straight? I mean, he looked up to you as an older brother. Did he have the reaction of basically saying, you've shown me something that I hadn't seen? He tried to placate me. He just stared down at the ground while I was talking. He was nodding his head, listening to me, but not really looking at me, not really taking in what I was saying. And he just kind of, in a way that even I didn't quite believe at the time, just said, thank you, Nafispey. Thank you. I understand. I understand what you're saying. And then
当你这么说时，他的反应是什么？他有没有说：“谢谢你把我拉回正轨”？我的意思是，他一直把你当成老大哥。他有没有那种基本上是在说“你让我看到了我以前没有看到的东西”的反应？他试图安抚我。自我说话时，他一直盯着地面。他在点头，听我说话，但并没有真正看着我，也没有真正把我的话听进去。然后他以一种甚至连我当时都觉得不太相信的方式说：“谢谢你，纳菲斯。谢谢你。我理解。我理解你在说什么。”接着
he just basically agreed that we would pick up the fieldwork again. We would do it in a few days. And he said, thank you. And then he just got up and just walked away. He didn't really even turn to me or anything. He just stood right up and just walked back towards where he came from. And then the research assistant broke off all contact with Nafis.
他基本上同意我们会重新开始实地工作。我们会在几天后进行。他说：“谢谢。”然后他就站起身走开了。他甚至都没有回头看我一眼之类。他直接站起身，朝着他来的方向走回去了。然后这位研究助理切断了与纳菲斯的所有联系。
I sent him messages. I was asking him, are we going to meet up? I tried to call him. I realized the phone had been disconnected. We were following each other on social media, so I went and checked the social media profile and I saw that the user had been deleted essentially. And, you know, I feared the worst. My mind goes into the direction of did he go off and join a group or something or go to Syria. Nafis considered trying to track the research assistant down,
我给他发了消息。我问他我们还要见面吗，我尝试打电话给他。我发现他的电话已经停机了。我们在社交媒体上互相关注，所以我去查看了那个社交媒体个人资料，发现那个账号基本上已经被注销了。而且，你知道的，我往最坏处想。我的脑海里浮现出他是不是跑去加入某个组织或者去了叙利亚。纳菲斯曾考虑过去追踪这位研究助理，
but he didn't know where he lived. So he tried an alternate route. He went to one of the assistant's cousins to do some digging for him. That guy says, okay, he'll do some investigation. He didn't want to talk to me on the phone. He said, just come back one week later. So for a whole week, I'm just kind of sweating bullets, you know, metaphorically speaking. Like, I just don't really know what's going on, what happened to him. I come back and I meet with the cousin and he tells me basically that the parents
但他不知道他住在哪里。于是他尝试了另一条途径。他去找了这位助理的一个表弟，想打听点消息。那个人说，好吧，他去调查一下。他不想在电话里跟我谈。他说：“你一个星期后再来。”所以在整整一个星期里，我心里都七上八下的，（从隐喻意义上讲）就像在冒冷汗。真的，我真的不知道发生了什么，他到底怎么了。我回来后和那个表弟见了面，他基本上告诉我，他的父母
sort of found out what was going on with him and then the parents basically said, okay, we can send you abroad to another Western country where you can get a job at a family acquaintances business, work part time, send some of that money back to us, and then you can pursue some of your grander ambitions that you have while you're there. So that way we get the money that we need and you can still pursue the things you want to pursue. And supposedly that's what he went off and did. Ironically, the parents did what Nafi should have done. Instead of trying to convince the young man that his beliefs were wrong,
不知怎么发现了他的近况，然后他的父母基本上说：“好吧，我们可以把你送到海外的另一个西方国家，你在那里的一家家族熟人的企业里找份工作，做兼职，把一部分钱寄回给我们，同时你可以在那里追求你的一些更宏大的抱负。”这样一来，我们得到了需要的钱，而你仍然可以追求你想要追求的事物。据推论，这就是他离开并去做的事情。具有讽刺意味的是，父母做了纳菲斯本该做的事。父母没有试图说服这个年轻人他的信念是错误的，
they offered him an opportunity to chase his dreams. As soon as those pathways for purpose and meaning and really inclusion in terms of his life and his dreams, once those pathways opened back up to him again, he dropped his flirtation with radicalization and went off and pursued his ambitions. When we come back, Nafis discovers more methods we can use to deter the spread of radicalization. And he said to me, he goes, Nafis, I can't live in that world.
而是为他提供了一个追逐梦想的机会。一旦那些通往人生目标、意义以及在他的人生和梦想中真正获得接纳的途径重新为他打开，他就放弃了对激进化的试探，转而前去追求自己的宏图大志。稍后回来，纳菲斯将发现更多我们可以用来遏制激进化蔓延的方法。他对我说，他说：“纳菲斯，我无法生活在那个世界里。
That world gives me anxiety. The world of QAnon, even if it's wrong, it at least tells me where the bad guy is. It gives me a direction of which way to point my gun. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Across the world, politically fueled violence This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Across the world, politically fueled violence is on the rise. People from different backgrounds are joining extremist groups,
那个世界让我感到焦虑。QAnon的世界，即使它是错的，它至少能告诉我坏人在哪里。它给我指明了把枪口对准哪个方向的方向。”你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在世界各地，由政治煽动的暴力这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在世界各地，由政治煽动的暴力正在上升。来自不同背景的人们正在加入极端主义组织，
willing to fight and even die for their beliefs. Nafis Hamid studies the psychology of extremism. In his initial research, he was able to identify how social exclusion often paves the path to radical ideologies, which left him to wonder, is there a way to pull people from the grip of such ideologies? So he set out on another study. This time, he gathered a group of Pakistani men living in Barcelona. Unlike the volunteers in the initial study, these men were fully radicalized, or what Nafis calls, devoted actors.
甘愿为他们的信仰战斗甚至牺牲。纳菲斯·哈米德研究极端主义心理学。在他的初步研究中，他得以确定社交排斥是如何为激进意识形态铺平道路的，这让他不禁好奇：有没有办法把人们从这种意识形态的魔掌中拉回来？于是他着手开展另一项研究。这一次，他召集了一群住在巴塞罗那的巴基斯坦男子。与初步研究中的志愿者不同，这些男子已经完全被激进化，或者说被纳菲斯称为“献身型行动者”（devoted actors）。
Devoted actors is a term that basically just means that there are some people who sometimes think about the world in very duty-bound ways, and they're willing to commit extreme costly sacrifices for their group or for their values. They're gonna fight and die for it, they'll kill people, they'll even kill themselves if they need to. The Pakistani men he recruited for the study were devoted actors to Lashkar-e-Taiba, an extremist Islamic group whose main mission is to fight India and force it to turn over the disputed state of Kashmir
“执着行动者”这个词基本上是指，有些人有时会以高度遵循义务的方式思考世界，他们愿意为自己的群体或价值观做出极具代价的极端牺牲。他们会为此战斗并牺牲，他们会杀人，如果有必要，他们甚至会自杀。他为研究招募的巴基斯坦男子是虔诚的真主军（Lashkar-e-Taiba）成员，这是一个极端伊斯兰组织，其主要使命是打击印度并迫使其交出有争议的克什米尔邦
to Pakistan. For them we want to understand what will bring them back from the edge of violence because they're already very close to it and they're already pretty extreme. Once again, Nafis asked the men to get into an fMRI machine. The volunteers were presented with a series of sacred and non-sacred values and then asked about their willingness to fight and die for those values. When the men were asked about sacred values, Nafis found one part of their brains appeared to be deactivated. Called the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex, which is associated with many things, but including sort of executive functions,
给巴基斯坦。对他们来说，我们想了解是什么能把他们从暴力的边缘拉回来，因为他们已经非常接近边缘，而且已经相当极端。纳菲斯再次要求这些人进入fMRI机器。志愿者被展示了一系列神圣和非神圣的价值观，然后被问及他们为这些价值观战斗和牺牲的意愿。当被问及神圣价值观时，纳菲斯发现他们大脑的一部分似乎处于停用状态。这被称为背外侧前额叶皮层，它与许多事情有关，包括诸如执行功能之类的东西、
deliberative cognition, self-control, emotional regulation, etc. Essentially, this is the part of the brain that makes you take a moment to stop and think. Should I do this? Why am I doing this? Simultaneously, another part of the brain, and that's the ventromedial prefrontal cortex, seem to show heightened activation. Another part of the brain, and that's the ventromedial prefrontal cortex, seemed to show heightened activation. This part of the brain is involved with emotion, reward, motivation, and fear. But when asked about non-sacred values, the
刻意认知、自我控制、情绪调节等。本质上，这是大脑中让你停下来思考一会儿的部分。我该这么做吗？我为什么要这么做？与此同时，大脑的另一部分——也就是腹内侧前额叶皮层，似乎表现出高度激活。大脑的另一部分——也就是腹内侧前额叶皮层，似乎表现出高度激活。大脑的这一部分与情绪、奖励、动机和恐惧有关。但当被问及非神圣价值观时，
researchers did not see differences between these two areas of the brain. The standard example that I usually give when I tell people about the study is, imagine you're out at a restaurant and you've had a nice dinner and the waiter comes and offers you a menu and there's some nice dessert in there. You might see a nice tiramisu or something and you go, oh I want that. That, if I was scanning your brain there's a pretty good chance I would be seeing the ventromedial prefrontal cortex active in that moment going, oh I want. Then you go, oh you know I gotta go to, I'm trying to lose weight, I'm going to the gym. I went to the gym yesterday. I didn't go today. Maybe I'll go tomorrow. I don't know. This is not really a good
研究人员没有发现大脑这两个区域之间的差异。我告诉人们这项研究时通常给出的标准例子是，想象你出去在一家餐厅吃了一顿不错的晚餐，服务员过来递给你一份菜单，里面有一些不错的甜点。你可能会看到一块美味的提拉米苏之类的东西，然后你会想，哦，我想要那个。如果我当时在扫描你的大脑，很有可能会看到腹内侧前额叶皮层在那一刻处于活跃状态，好像在说，哦，我想要。然后你会想，哦，你知道我得去，我正在努力减肥，我要去健身房。我昨天去了健身房。我今天没去。也许我明天去。我不知道。这其实不是一个好
decision here. If I was scanning your brain at that moment, I might see the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex active. And you'll see these two parts of the brain competing over each other. And maybe one will win out. You might say, hey, you know, I want that. I want that term of sewer. I might not. So that's normal decision making that takes place. And when it comes to non-sacred values, it's basically the same. Even for these supporters of Lushkriyat Theba, when there's non-sacred values, you see that normal activity of decision making going on. But you don't see it when it comes to sacred values. It's just the I want part of the brain that seems to be online.
这里的决定。如果我在那一刻扫描你的大脑，我可能会看到背外侧前额叶皮层处于活跃状态。你会看到大脑的这两个部分相互竞争。也许其中一个会胜出。你可能会说，嘿，你知道，我想要那个。我想要那个提拉米苏。我也可能不想要。这就是发生的正常决策过程。当谈到非神圣价值观时，情况基本相同。即使对于这些真主军的支持者来说，当涉及非神圣价值观时，你会看到正常的决策活动在进行。但当涉及到神圣价值观时，你看不到这一点。似乎只有大脑中“我想要”的部分在运转。
Nafis and his team wanted to see if it was possible to counter that I want response with more measured and thoughtful brain activity. As he'd learned with his research assistant, it usually doesn't work to try and convince someone that their beliefs are wrong. So Nafis and his colleagues took a different tack. that their beliefs are wrong. So Nafis and his colleagues took a different tack. We thought to ourselves, okay, maybe what we can do is we can't change their sacred value, but we can change what they're willing to do for their sacred values. We can change their intentions. We can change their action propensity. Maybe we can lower their willingness to fight and die for these beliefs without changing the beliefs themselves. Okay, that's probably a more realistic goal.
纳菲斯和他的团队想要看看是否有可能用更有条理、更深思熟虑的大脑活动来对抗“我想要”的反应。正如他从他的研究助理那里了解到的那样，试图说服某人他们的信仰是错误的通常是行不通的。所以纳菲斯和他的同事们采取了不同的策略。即他们的信仰是错误的。所以纳菲斯和他的同事们采取了不同的策略。我们心里想，好吧，也许我们能做的是，我们无法改变他们的神圣价值观，但我们可以改变他们愿意为神圣价值观做的事情。我们可以改变他们的意图。我们可以改变他们的行动倾向。也许我们可以降低他们为这些信念战斗和牺牲的意愿，而不改变这些信念本身。好吧，这可能是一个更现实的目标。
How do you change someone's intentions? How do you get someone to back away from their sacred values, let alone say no to the tiramisu? Again, it comes back to that basic human need to belong. If you want to stay belonging into a particular group, you have to follow the social norms of that group. The more you deviate from the social norms of the group, the more you're sort of othering yourself. You're hacking away at your own sense of belonging. And we
你如何改变一个人的意图？你怎么能让一个人背离他们神圣的价值观，更不用说对提拉米苏说不呢？这再次归结为人类对归属感的基本需求。如果你想继续归属于某个特定群体，你就必须遵循该群体的社会规范。你越是偏离群体的社会规范，你其实就越是在将自己边缘化。你正在削弱你自己的归属感。我们
normally wouldn't want to do that. You know, we want to follow the social norms. So if the social norms shift, we shift along with it oftentimes in order to maintain our sense of safety that comes with belonging. Was it possible, in other words, not to shift the views of the volunteers, but to shift
通常不会想这么做。你知道，我们想要遵循社会规范。因此，如果社会规范发生变化，我们往往也会随之改变，以维持归属感带来的安全感。换句话说，是否可能不改变志愿者的观点，而是改变
their perception of the social norms of the groups they cared about? The researchers once again had the men climb into the fMRI scanner. They could see each sacred and non-sacred value that had been shown in the first half of the study, along with a little green square that represented how willing they were to fight and die for each value. But that wasn't all they saw. They see in a red square what the general opinion of the Pakistani community in Barcelona
他们对所关心的群体的社会规范的感知？研究人员再次让这些男子进入fMRI扫描仪。他们可以看到在研究前半部分展示的每个神圣和非神圣价值观，以及一个小绿方块，代表他们为每个价值观战斗和牺牲的意愿。但这并不是他们看到的全部。他们从一个红方块中看到巴塞罗那巴基斯坦社区的总体意见
was in terms of their willingness to fight and die for this particular value. And they knew that we were out there doing surveys with lots of people. They knew that we had access to this data. The radicalized men saw there was a large gap between their views and the views of the broader Pakistani community. Suddenly, the researchers noticed a shift in the brain imaging data.
就他们为这个特定价值战斗和牺牲的意愿而言。他们知道我们在外面和很多人一起做调查。他们知道我们有权访问这些数据。被激进化的男子看到他们的观点与更广泛的巴基斯坦社区的观点之间存在巨大差距。突然间，研究人员注意到脑成像数据发生了变化。
Parts of the volunteers' brains that focused on executive functioning, asking, should I do this? And, this really make sense? Showed increased activation. They lowered their willingness to fight and die to get closer to what the actual general community said. And the degree to which they conformed was predicted by the degree of reactivation of the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex. So in other words, really what's happening here, if you can tell a story about this research, is that they are seeing that their views in some ways are more extreme than the views of people whom they consider to be their in-group. And something
志愿者大脑中专注于执行功能的部分，询问“我应该这样做吗？”以及“这真的有意义吗？”显示出增加的激活。他们降低了为战斗和牺牲以更接近实际普通社区所说的情况的意愿。他们顺从的程度可以通过背外侧前额叶皮层的重新激活程度来预测。换句话说，这里真正发生的事情，如果你能讲述关于这项研究的故事，那就是他们看到他们的观点在某些方面比他们认为是内群体的人的观点更极端。有些事情
is happening in their brains that basically says, let me become more in line with the views of people in my in-group." Yeah, so basically, what I think is going on here is essentially, yeah, they see that this, my in-group doesn't agree with my willingness to fight and die. I think that's sort of like this error detection, right? It's like, oh, I'm out of, maybe I shouldn't be so confident about my answer to this willingness to fight and die, because I'm out of line. And again, there's a threat and there's a, again, there's a threat, there's a danger here. These are a group of people that I want to belong to.
正在他们的大脑中发生，基本上是在说，让我与内群体中人们的观点更加一致。“是的，所以基本上，我认为这里发生的事情本质上是，是的，他们看到这，我的内群体不同意我为之战斗和牺牲的意愿。我认为这有点像这种错误检测，对吧？就像，哦，我脱节了，也许我不应该对这个关于战斗和牺牲意愿的答案如此自信，因为我脱节了。再次，这里存在威胁，再次，这里存在威胁，这里存在危险。这是一群我想要归属的人。
The story painted by this research has been demonstrated in many other settings. Princeton University psychologist Betsy Palak found that when Hutus and Tutsis in post-genocide Rwanda were led to think that most Rwandans were for reconciliation, they started to favor reconciliation themselves. We explored that research in an earlier episode of Hidden Brain titled Romeo and Juliet in Kigali.
这项研究所描绘的故事已在许多其他环境中得到证实。普林斯顿大学心理学家贝茨·帕拉克（Betsy Palak）发现，当卢旺达大屠杀后的胡图族人和图西族人被引导认为大多数卢旺达人赞成和解时，他们自己也开始赞成和解。我们在《隐藏的大脑》早期的一集名为《基加利的罗密欧与朱丽叶》中探讨了这项研究。
For his own part, Nafis says he has come to see the pointlessness of trying to argue people out of their beliefs. Debates on social media or across the dinner table rarely change the minds of people with strong pre-existing views. A better approach is to focus again on building bonds with our interlocutors and then counting on those bonds to change how people think. Nafis got to try this approach himself when he noticed a former flatmate behaving oddly.
就他自己而言，纳菲斯说他已经认识到试图说服人们放弃信仰是毫无意义的。社交媒体上或餐桌上的辩论很少能改变那些有着强烈原有观点的人的想法。更好的方法是重新专注于与我们的对话者建立纽带，然后依靠这些纽带改变人们的思考方式。当纳菲斯注意到一个前室友行为古怪时，他自己也尝试了这种方法。
So this was someone who I had lived with many years earlier, almost a decade earlier at that point. And I had known him as a young person. I was maybe eight years older than him or so. And he also looked up to me. He was a white American. And he and I sort of lost touch over the years. I mean, we stayed in touch over social media.
所以这是一个我很多年前住在一起的人，当时几乎是十年前了。我认识他时他还很年轻。我可能比他大八岁左右。他也仰望我。他是一个白人美国人。这些年来，我和他有点失去联系了。我的意思是，我们在社交媒体上保持着联系。
We sent messages to each other. And then the pandemic hit in 2020. And I could see on social media that he was kind of posting a lot of extreme content. I noticed that he was specifically going after some people on social media, some people that we mutually knew who were Jewish, or at least it seemed like he was targeting them and calling them out and saying that they're just believing whatever the cabal tells them and that they need to trust the plan
我们互相发消息。然后2020年大流行来袭。我可以在社交媒体上看到他发布了很多极端内容。我注意到他专门在社交媒体上针对一些人，一些我们共同认识的犹太人，或者至少看起来他在针对他们并大声指责他们，说他们只是相信阴谋集团告诉他们的一切，他们需要相信计划
and they need to trust Q and Q has all the answers and that they're part of the problem. The Q that Nafis's former flatmate was referring to is a person or people responsible for the group QAnon, which spreads misinformation about a variety of topics in the United States and beyond. Rather than calling out his friend online or chastising him like he had done with his research assistant, Nafis asked his former flatmate if he'd be willing to talk. When they got on a video call,
他们需要相信Q，Q拥有一切答案，他们是问题的一部分。纳菲斯的前室友所指的Q是负责QAnon组织的个人或群体，该组织在美国及其他地区传播关于各种主题的错误信息。纳菲斯没有像对他的研究助理那样在网上痛斥他的朋友或惩罚他，而是问他的前室友是否愿意谈谈。当他们进行视频通话时，
it was clear his friend was having a rough time. He didn't look like that nice starry-eyed cute little boy that I knew when he was younger. He was now a man and a man who looked like he had aged quite a bit as well and seemed like he had seen a lot of stress in his life. And the initial conversation was a bit stilted. He was a bit ideological. But at this point, I had actually had so much experience talking to people with ideas that are very different than my own. I really knew how to navigate the situation, which was just to ask a lot of questions and for him to feel like he's being heard. And he eventually revealed to me, like his whole journey down the QAnon rabbit hole and even into more far right wing ideology.
很明显他的朋友过得很艰难。他看起来不像我年轻时认识的那个讨人喜欢的、眼中闪烁着星光的可爱小男孩了。他现在是一个男人，一个看起来苍老了不少的男人，而且似乎在他的生活中经历了很多压力。最初的交谈有点生硬。他有点意识形态化。但此时此刻，我实际上已经有了很多与有着与我截然不同的想法的人交谈的经验。我真的知道如何驾驭这种情况，那就是问很多问题让他觉得自己被倾听了。他最终向我透露了，比如他陷入QAnon兔子洞甚至更右翼意识形态的整个旅程。
And what basically ended up happening was that he had a series of sort of events that happened in his life, losing his job, relationship breaking up, family members, loved ones dying, and it all happened in very short order. And this really created a sense of being lost in his life, because all the things that gave him a sense of who he was and a sense of stability were just sort of stripped away from him in quite short order. Unemployed, lonely, and stuck at home during the pandemic,
基本上最终发生的事情是，他的生活中发生了一系列事件，失业、恋爱关系破裂、家庭成员、挚爱离世，这一切都在很短的时间内发生了。这确实在他心中营造了一种迷失的感觉，因为所有赋予他自我认同感和稳定感的事物都在相当短的时间内被剥夺了。在大流行期间失业、孤独并被困在家中，
Nafis's friend had started spending a lot of time on YouTube. It began with popular alt-right channels, which led to conspiracy theory videos, and eventually to QAnon. QAnon gave him a bad guy. They gave him a bad guy that could just be responsible for all the world's problems. At the end of like a 10-hour conversation, I could tell that he understood that I didn't understand really what was motivating him. And so he sat there and he goes,
纳菲斯的朋友开始在YouTube上花大量时间。它始于流行的另类右翼频道，这导致了阴谋论视频，并最终导致了QAnon。QAnon给了他一个坏人。他们给了他一个坏人，可以为世界上所有的麻烦负责。在进行了大约10个小时的对话结束时，我能看出他明白我并不真正理解是什么在激励他。所以他坐在那里说，
okay, let me try to figure myself out with you. And he says to me, he goes, listen, my family were preppers. We had like 10 guns, 10,000 rounds of ammunition, and enough food and water for us to survive the zombie apocalypse if it came along. I'm an anxious person. I can't handle uncertainty. I need a contingency plan for everything. And he said to me, he goes, if there's no real good guys or bad guys, there's no one person who's creating all the trouble in the world. It's just, it's kind of chaotic. You know, you have this chaos theory, you have all these
好吧，让我试着跟你一起弄清楚我自己。他对我说，听着，我的家人是末日生存狂。我们有大约10支枪、10,000发子弹，还有足够的食物和水，如果僵尸末日降临，我们可以生存下来。我是一个焦虑的人。我无法处理不确定性。我需要为每件事制定应急计划。他对我说，如果没有真正的善良的人或坏人，没有一个人在世界上制造所有的麻烦。这只是，这有点混乱。你知道，你有这个混沌理论，你拥有所有这些
different power players all trying to do their own thing, and then sort of things emerge out of that complex interaction. Because even if that's the way the world is, I can't live in that world. That world gives me anxiety. The world of QAnon, even if it's wrong, it at least tells me where the bad guy is. It gives me a direction of which way to point my gun. In essence, it gives him a map to a territory. And so he can navigate that world more easily. Although this was unsettling, Nafis just kept having open conversations with his friend. He wanted to give him a space outside the radical world of QAnon where he could feel understood, where he could feel like he belonged.
不同的权力玩家都在试图做他们自己的事情，然后事情从这种复杂的互动中浮现出来。因为即使世界就是这样，我也无法生活在那个世界里。那个世界让我感到焦虑。QAnon的世界，即使它是错的，它至少告诉我坏人在哪里。它给我指明了枪口应该指向的方向。本质上，它为他提供了通往领土的地图。因此，他可以更轻松地驾驭这个世界。尽管这令人不安，但纳菲斯只是继续与他的朋友进行公开对话。他想在QAnon的激进世界之外为他提供一个空间，在那里他可以感到被理解，在那里他可以感受到归属感。
These conversations lasted hours. Nafis gained his friend's trust, going so far as to become what psychologists call a credible messenger. Credible messenger needs to have at least two qualities. One is a perception of benevolence that this person has my best interests are hurt and two that this person has authority, that they know more about the topic than I do. And I knew from his eyes he saw me as having both of those qualities. So he respected me and he knew that I respected him as a person. And so I became a credible messenger for him where we would have these
这些对话持续了几个小时。纳菲斯赢得了朋友的信任，甚至成为了心理学家所说的可信信使。可信信使需要具备至少两个品质。一是仁慈的感知，这个人最符合我的利益；二是这个人有权威，他们对这个话题的了解比我多。我知道从他的眼中，他认为我具备这两种品质。所以他尊重我，他也知道我作为一个人尊重他。因此，我成为了他的可信信使，我们会有这些
conversations where he would post something that was clearly a conspiracy ideology based thinking or what I would consider sometimes hate-demongering messages, us versus them, divisive messages, sometimes with undertones of anti-Semitism. But I knew that as the credible messenger in his life, I could in a nice way, in a polite way, in a respectful way, engage with him about it and say, listen, I don't think this message is quite true because look at this alternative information. And because I had brought him in and became sort of one source of inclusion for him, he was open to what I was saying. Over time, the friend became more and more willing to have Nafis challenge his extremist
谈话，他会发布一些明显基于阴谋意识形态思考的内容，或者我有时认为的仇恨煽动信息、我们与他们之间的分裂信息，有时带有反犹太主义的暗色调。但我知道，作为他生活中的可信信使，我可以以一种美好、礼貌、尊重的方式与他探讨这个问题，并说，听着，我认为这个消息不完全正确，因为看看这个替代信息。因为我把他拉了进来，并成为他的一种包容来源，他对我说的话持开放态度。随着时间的推移，这位朋友越来越愿意让纳菲斯挑战他的极端主义
beliefs. He posted less and less. He got a girlfriend who didn't support his radical ideas, and with Nafis' encouragement, pursued a new line of work. Q became a thing of his past. Most people don't want to say or even admit to themselves that they believed in something that perhaps they don't agree with anymore, but they just simply walk away from it and they just move on with other things in their life. They don't wanna talk about it anymore.
信仰。他发帖越来越少。他交了一个不支持他激进思想的女朋友，在纳菲斯的鼓励下，追求了一份新工作。Q成了他过去的事情。大多数人不想说甚至向自己承认他们曾经相信过某种他们可能不再认同的东西，但他们只是简单地离开它，继续他们生活中的其他事情。他们不想再谈论它了。
And I would say he's kind of more in that phase. I have to say though, the model that you're suggesting here, it's such a difficult model for many people to practice, right? Because if someone does something that we find, you know, not just wrong, but deeply offensive, deeply hurtful, that angers us, it's very hard to remember that our ability to influence them comes down to their being able to trust us.
我想说他更处于那个阶段。不过我必须说，你在这里建议的模式，对许多人来说是一个很难实践的模式，对吧？因为如果有人做了我们发现的不仅是错误的，而且是深深冒犯的、深深伤害的、让我们生气的事情，我们很难记住我们影响他们的能力归结为他们能够信任我们。
And therefore, we should actually reach out to them and make them feel included when everything in our body is screaming to us to exclude them. Yeah. And you have to remember, are you doing this for you or are you doing this for them? All right. Because sometimes it can feel personally cathartic and feel good to get upset at them. And sometimes it's almost we don't realize it, but maybe we're even being a bit performative in our anger because this is what our in-group would think is the righteous way and the virtuous way to behave. And even if there's nobody else watching, we might be virtue signaling because we've just intrinsically hold these values now. But it's not always
因此，当我们的身体里的一切都在尖叫着排斥他们时，我们实际上应该向他们伸出援手，让他们感到被包容。是的。你必须记住，你这样做是为了你自己还是为了他们？好吧。因为有时对他们生气的个人宣泄和感觉良好会让人感觉很好。有时甚至我们自己都没有意识到，但也许我们在愤怒中表现得有点表演性，因为这是我们的内群体会认为是正义和美德的行事方式。即使没有人看着，我们也可能在进行美德信号传递，因为我们现在已经内化了这些价值观。但这并不总是
going to be the useful and the right way to actually help navigate someone into a different pathway. If you want to transform another person's life, you have to really transform your relationship with them. I think this is the big myth of individualism, is we think that we can exist independently, but we don't. We only exist in relation to other people, and everyone else exists in relation to everyone else. And so if you want to transform an individual person, in some sense you have to transform yourself as well. You have to change the relationship and be open to the fact that not only are you going to maybe transform their way of thinking, but maybe you'll also change
将是帮助引导某人走向不同途径的有用且正确的方法。如果你想改变另一个人的生活，你必须真正改变你与他们的关系。我认为这是个人主义的弥天大谎，我们认为我们可以独立存在，但我们不能。我们只存在于与他人的关系中，其他人也存在于与其他人的关系中。因此，如果你想改变一个个人，在某种意义上你也必须改变你自己。你必须改变这种关系，并对以下事实持开放态度：你不仅可能会改变他们的思维方式，而且你也可能会改变
in terms of having more empathy for them and hopefully even more compassion for them as well. Nafis Hameed is a cognitive scientist at King's College London. Nafis, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. I had a great time. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirrell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Burns, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy our work, there's plenty more for you to listen to as a member of our podcast
就对他们有更多的同理心而言，希望甚至对他们有更多的同情心。纳菲斯·哈米德是伦敦国王学院的认知科学家。纳菲斯，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。我玩得很开心。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥秋恩·伯恩斯、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢我们的工作，作为我们播客的会员，你还有很多内容可以听
subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. Hidden Brain Plus is now available across podcast platforms and devices. You can sign up for a free 7-day trial by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you use Apple devices, you can find Hidden Brain Plus in Apple podcasts or at apple.co slash hidden brain. Once again, those links are support.hiddenbrain.org and apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
订阅，《隐藏的大脑+》。《隐藏的大脑+》现已在各个播客平台和设备上推出。您可以访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 注册 7 天免费试用。如果您使用的是 Apple 设备，您可以在 Apple podcasts 或 apple.co 加上 hidden brain 中找到《隐藏的大脑+》。再次重申，这些链接是 support.hiddenbrain.org 和 apple.co 加上 hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。音乐 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。